what advice do you receive for your
wedding night in a culture you know we
don't have sex before we get married so
it's not actually sex advice we get more
we get more marriage advices why do you
think our culture shroud sex with so
much shame
we think it's immodest to talk about it
even if it's not explicit I think we
still don't talk about it because it's
coupled with being explicit I just don't
think that I was like kind of allowed to
talk about on the go this is just
something like we do and we never talk
about it
and then eventually if I like need
specific advice maybe when I'm like 40 I
can ask her but I'm surprised at that
cuz I thought you could ask me anything
we never had I talked about it yeah so
how would I know that that door was open
for me to talk about it do you have any
questions you want to ask me no no when
was the first time you saw a male organ
I decide in a movie I remember being
like oh why did where do they put it it
was terrified I was like it's long and
weird looking and I don't know where
they put it in their pants I think I was
like 11 years old when I saw that movie
was like a flash and I remember renting
that movie again later so that I could
see what was the first male or again you
someone I saw man peeing on decided this
is should I said what is that he's
holding and I asked my brother that he
says he was really mad at me for asking
that question
did you and dad ever watch porn together
doesn't every couple yes I did yeah we
did I was not exposed to it before
I thought it was gross I did not like
much why what did you not like about it
made it look dirty and not because I
think intimacy should come with
affection and not just the animal
instinct did he ever ask you to watch it
again
yeah he did did you say no because you
didn't like it the first time yeah we
watched a few times but you don't want
to hear that I don't know talking about
everything
watching it helps to put you in the mood
beautiful I think that's the only
positive thing I would say that watching
porn but you feel like you've missed out
by not by only being with dad but I not
dating any other people yeah when I'm
mad at him I think I wish I had some
more experience and he often blames
tells me that you know you don't know
how when we have a fight he says you you
know you don't know how to deal with guy
because you never dated so I he made me
feel like it was a flaw in me but I was
also always thinking I'm preserving
myself for my husband you know yeah
sometimes I do feel I wish I had some
more experience about not physical
experience but knowing men in another
way yes do you wish we had this
conversation earlier in your life I mean
like yes and now do you think I had not
having it earlier in life affected you
wrongly in any way I mean probably a
little bit maybe it informed my
relationship with men a little bit right
like I'm very a nervous dater and a
little insecure and I think maybe if I
felt a little bit more confident and
things I know and maybe I wouldn't be
sad to hear I know you are crowd
pleasers inside but I know that when it
comes to your personal judgement you
were already there at 18 you were
already there that you would not do
something that you thought was wrong
Thanks all right mom
last question yes what wedding I
would you give me I would tell you that
it's your body and you have a right over
your body and if you want don't feel
comfortable in doing certain things you
don't need to do it okay and you have to
take charge of your body okay also but
you know you have to be considerate of
each other like I would expect your
husband to be considered of you and you
you have to be considerate of your
husband even though the romance does
happen f but it happened mostly after
engagement or you were bit throat to
somebody because no one is is how hard
hitting work and from old school